il établit et d'époque et les techniques
bien rodées alexandre lienhard 20 ans de
métier joue avec le feu pour fondre de
l'or rose à 1063 degrés dans sa
bijouterie
il prend de leurs massifs on utilise de
l'or à 18 carats et pas du neuf ou 10 14
carats qui est une durée de vie beaucoup
moins et le but c'est vraiment que le
bijou soit portée et dure 20 ans 30 ans
50 ans pour mettre en forme cette petite
boule
il utilise le laminoir après plusieurs
passages il obtient une forme allongée
régulièrement ils doivent vérifier que
les dimensions sont bien respectées il
faut de la précision n'est pas seulement
ça demande beaucoup de patience
il ya des fois quand ça va pas faut
savoir rebondir repartir de zéro et même
si des fois ça fait pas plaisir
ce qui compte c'est réellement le
résultat à la fin leur travail et prend
la forme d'un anneau en utilisant une
pince et le maillet extérieur et
l'intérieur sont émerisé c'est-à-dire
pons et puis la touche finale
le polissage les polices ageron l'état
de surface impeccable d'une brillance
miroir éclatante et
c'est tout de suite la partie qu'on
affectionne le plus parce qu'on a un
rendu de bijoux qui est éclatant
brillant mais ici les états pas bon donc
pas été bien réalisé ça ça va venir pour
lire voilà le résultat final un bel
anneau fabriqué en quelques minutes
devant les visiteurs
je suis technicien la base mais c'est
vrai que de voir cette technique la
patience le la précision qu'il est
nécessaire aussi pour faire un bijou
dans les différentes étapes vraiment
très intéressant colliers broches
bracelet dans cet atelier près de 400
bijoux ils sont fabriqués chaque année